[Music]
Netflix's horror series the haunting of
Hill House earned critical acclaim for
its first season it's a modern
reimagining of the classic novel by
Shirley Jackson but the highlight of the
show is the two storms episode the sixth
one in the season the fifty-three minute
episode looks like it was filmed in one
long continuous shot seamlessly
transitioning between parallel
storylines in the past and present the
effect is seriously unsettling but how
exactly did the cast and crew pull this
off first series creator Mike Flanagan
made an ambitious play a film the bulk
of the episode in just five unedited
takes with a centerpiece tracking shot
that last 17 minutes long for this
challenge
Flanagan joined forces with Michael fimo
yari the cinematographer behind another
Netflix hit to all the boys I've loved
before Hill House was their seventh
project together following a string of
hit horror films but this one episode
presented the biggest challenge of their
careers to date the action unfolds in
two settings a tense family reunion at
the cranes funeral home in the present
and a stormy night they spent at Hill
House in the past even in the early
phases of production both the funeral
home and Hill House were designed with
the needs of episode six in mind the
stages had to be adjacent and connected
by a hallway so that Hugh Crain could
walk from the funeral home directly into
his past the sets also had to include
hiding places for crew equipment and
special lighting rigs along with secret
access portals for the actors and their
photo doubles to sprint through as the
scenes slit between past and present
once the set pieces were built
production was shut down for a month so
that they could focus on rehearsing the
episode with second team stand-ins
they'd walk through the and
script over and over and over again so
that the crew could learn all the
blocking lighting and camera
choreography by heart it was a dance
that they rehearsed and rehearsed and
rehearsed this also gave him a chance to
figure out the hundreds of camera and
lighting cues which would serve as
signals for the cast and crew to carry
out specific actions at the correct
times those actions could include
anything from a special effect to a set
movement a lighting change or a camera
pivot after the first cues were
important for getting the beauty
lighting right - if a cue was earlier
late or a cast member missed their mark
then the actors wouldn't be lit properly
once a minute that goes bad you have to
start over so there's a lot of pressure
and a lot of excitement the third shot
was the hardest it was the longest it
represented the most physical challenges
the following shot was only about a
third of the lane but it presented the
most technical difficulty as the crew
basically had to teleport Olivia around
the set in terms of coordination
physical coordination it was a challenge
it required a lot of handoffs we had
doubles for Olivia that were flying in
and out of rooms they even built a
handmade elevator for shot 4 which
lowered the cameraman down to the first
floor of Hill House as Olivia and Hugh
ran down the stairs
the weather effects added yet another
layer of complexity episode 6 is set
against the backdrop of an ongoing rain
storm which is occurring in both the
present and past Hill house relied
mostly on practical wizardry for its
special effects and creating the storm
was no different they brought in
specialty lights to create the Lightning
and installed massive rain effects which
actually flooded the set a few times
during rehearsal we thought it was
important that you could feel the water
effects see the one section that was was
CG was where all the windows blow since
there would be very little editing done
in post-production the actors had no
room for error at all if one person made
a minor misstep or jumbled their lines
they all have to start over our young
cast they were incredible we didn't
change the way we do things for them
based on their age and so episode 6 was
no different they were part of the team
like everybody else this massive
undertaking was well worth it in the end
the single shot effect in Episode six
sucks you into the action subverting
both space and time
critics called it a standout episode in
a series that's gotten props from horror
auteur Stephen King we were exploring
ways that we could bring memory into the
present and blur those lines whether
that's something that's actually
occurring in a supernatural way or
something that's only happening in the
mind Hillhouse brought that to another
level to be able to look away from that
may reduced its intensity
it's not something we do every day but
it was right it was right for that
episode
[Music]